who is the real really a question
scientists have a Menendez for centuries
it's not right for fake booty pie yes
real cutie pie that is right that is
right so many imposters what if one of
them steals my girlfriend bucks yeah
that would break my heart
let's review the samples oh hey that is
unlicensed pity primers how many times I
gotta say this ain't no party like a
pity pie party snapback where did you
buy this and some damage how did I miss
how do I miss from this distance I got
it on eBay every $3 it was a great deal
goddamn unlicensed pity pie March when
will you stop buying into it
you call this the Peter pie logo Jesus
Christ
there's even intricate guidelines on how
to impersonate pretty pie you need some
Lightning and some tight pants
this one trying to steal underage women
well you so much wrong with this team
starts no sushi sushi that is not me I
promise
why does so many girls wanna dress up
kiss me hey that's if that's kind of
cute that's kind of here those [ __ ]
shoes man Jesus why is it so common to
try and steal my identity who are why
why do these people keep trying that
[ __ ] is this oh it's that imposter guy
it's that guy with the he's got a big
chin though big ups for that man that is
a nice [ __ ] chin actually can I just
say something look at this alright it
may not be a big chin but it's a chin
let's not say that is no chin because
it's definitely a chin if it wasn't a
chin it would've looked like different
now what's wrong with small chins
there's nothing wrong with small chance
stay the [ __ ] out of my boy leafy just
cuz you don't have a chin doesn't mean
you're not a man
you
but that [ __ ] is this poo fake 40 pi
that's right that is a fake phony pie
fake codify that fake prototypes really
good at dancing this oh boy that's
Talent
that's real talent oh my god this guy is
pretending to be PewDiePie
what that [ __ ] I'm all can't wait oh my
god these people are falling for I don't
talk like that
that ain't me That's not me I swear
Oh oh my god he's trying to get lady
it's trying really hard not to look at
her tick
[Music]
what the [ __ ] am i watching oh wow that
looks that looks just like me I can't
tell any difference that looks really
good that looks very that's my classic
face well well I've seen it all now I've
seen it I've seen it all thank you oh
these fake Peter pie it's trying to ruin
my rep not just underage girls but also
the KKK I have so many questions about
this photo I don't know where to begin
what the [ __ ] and what the [ __ ] look how
[ __ ] many there are Jesus Christ oh
betting me what the [ __ ] seriously Jesus
Christ
there's even professionals trying to
steal my likeness
I like how she painted the nostrils
because my nose is so [ __ ] huge she
had to paint nostrils to be bigger
that's how she looks like oh Jesus oh my
god there's even one for Marzia Jade sir
that's freaky man I can't I can't
that's more King hey guys it's your
friend candy there's no way she can look
like me okay I can't hear what the thing
on my ear this is so weird
no ain't nothing weird here this is just
me and fake pewdiepie reacting to
another girl that's fake poo pie I can't
do this anymore
I don't even know who I am anymore
anyway guys thanks for watching this
video don't forget to give it a thumbs
up but I morning to you laddies
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]